どっっ
というかみなさんね私はじめシャツを今年一年お肉が
くれません
もう限界でございます肉が食べたいです焼肉食べたい派が州入りのラーメンが食べたい
炙りカルビずしたみたいにマーグ食べた-バックと別離曲と国保どうー
ブー
そんな僕そんな僕に奇跡のような商品が舞い降りましたこちら
はいマグー投げもうパッと見ナゲットなんですけれども実は大豆ミートで作った r で
ナゲット
際 to meet で作った丸てナゲットのような食感の美味しさ
質はチキンナゲットの80%カットあーんだダイス画像をならだけするのは止めて
下さいペットカードですよ糞つまんねー
まつ毛を取った目初任者委が作ってくれた人ありがとぜ
やばい俺を狙った商品もしれないすごくナイス家だってこれはそれにナゲットなんです
よ食感も味もナゲットなんですけども大豆ミートと言われるお肉のような食感とおいし
さ火事場れる大豆加工商品らしいですねこれはお肉疲れないんですけどもナゲット
らしいですためにコンビニんぐ
ていましたん
は子だ俺惚れあったらもうに服用台じゃんって話になるんですけど勝ち格安車だけど
ちょっと食べてみますこれはもうそこに暮らしだとすると僕はもう3か月プレイお肉
などは強いわけですねこれは a でも肉じゃないもんねお肉じゃないんで僕は大丈夫
です変な罪悪感が生まれてきていますが
おっをターゲットてがなんかカラーゲっぽいですねもう見た目本当に何かちょっとし3
入ったナゲット唐揚げみたいな感じでございまして交通小さめですね家はこれを6って
言うように本当に入ってないわけだが入ってないです大豆ですでは擬似的にお肉3カ月
ぶりに食べますいただきます
[音楽]
ナゲットだぴぎゃーも横読みつの pets 芸
わかんないはずなぜとした想いなりたいというわけでこういう稀な毛ってですねもう
ず人的に成功ニックがあるんですけど今回はこのナゲット使って
急流を仕掛けたいと思います jal 皆さんよく考えてみてください僕はお肉を軽視
しているちなみに本気でやってます裏でも
阿部てないんですけども僕の周りの人は僕が裏でも食べてないことでも知っているわけ
ですよ後輩が部屋に入ってきてお肉絶対食べないマンの僕がその禁忌を犯してそれに
ラケットを振ってたらどうぞそしてどう反応するのかもう全然に僕は気になっており
ますでは撮影仕込んでいきましょう
金のターゲットに切る別として現地でショッカー get you お肉が入ってすと
オーナーも容器を準備しましたこの中にいかにもちょっと気味でお肉っぽい丸投げを
行うでもう詰めてそれからで僕はが歩数パクパク食べています周りから見るとどう見て
もにくくてそんな僕が高田入ってきたこれも見てなぜに起こって何も話さなかった
ん
スチールた
th
まあまあなんかちょっとまあ小さいの唐揚げには見えます
こんな感じでいかがでしょうかたいというわけで早速
仕掛ける部屋に入ってお肉を食べてみましょうでは行こう
[音楽]
ん
持った
おっ
うんん
[音楽]
いっ
on
[音楽]
の
お前に
何
ぜひ8が何言っ
4つではないマジでコア
あっ
[音楽]
吸ってると思ったうん裏で食ってると思ったねうっ
ねええええ
バーッ
[音楽]
いやだめじゃんっ
卒業しですうん
ちょっとし降ってるんでも
[音楽]
いやいや待って
いや肉ジャンヌ
何やってんすか本当にっ
[音楽]
飲んでるエッグ知央
ねえ
俺いいますからね
[音楽]
まず食ってるじゃないですかね
えっまーしーすとうっ
すべてでは
ています
[音楽]
そんな顔で見ないでいやべつべ別にいいですけど
いっ
[音楽]
いいですけどいいんですかーって感じだったんでを良かったんですけど食べたんやつ
まだ3軍への
まず多分4粒ぐらいしか食ってないにゃー
そのか思って食ってます
7弦来たーー
[音楽]
me
car
でも肉じゃなっちこれは
肉では
ございません中道と大きいネッツはこれたくさん買ったと言ったとして
すべてた夏に肉禁止などに食う時っていう
ほらっをポンポンファッ本当だ
やられたあーまぢあセッターでも